hello and welcome to see do plan kick
ass from the u.s. to 190 SS rating for
randoms oh yeah I really like the news
of effort why my book that will stay
main part of my openings I'd like to get
some more aggressive alternative for the
bogo though especially for the blitz
games where I also want a bogus solid
and very okay for high-level tournament
games for the Blitz share something a
little bit more aggressive however is
some yes it's not required as the wrong
word but I'd like to look let's say and
find something else okay tonight h form
h6 f1 ig6 system classical continuation
which are also having my book it's
sometimes a little bit difficult to play
this this position for win with black
and white has very little but sometimes
you you cannot cannot make much headway
with black we'll see what happens at
least I'm clearly ahead on the clock
white players normally take only five he
doesn't hmm okay
couple of options Queen to e7 it can
also take take a plane I g4 it's a move
I'm trying this I think that might give
more chances to to try for activity
okay what's aggressive I'll take it in
my cheek you might give him antique you
might give let's try some some complete
sentences and he probably will get get
get this porn porn back quite easily
okay um how to do this here yeah it's
kind of that's interesting
and now we had sets it's really
dangerous a queen coming to g6
and it's actually very dangerous um
Wow through a defenders
I don't see a move that's crazy huh
hi I don't see a bluefin this position
it's not a single one look I have six
takes Queen takes loses context will
also lose very likely at least
okay okay i know i have to play a move
Queen g6 look and six check that's also
losing
we have 60 X Queen takes Queen age seven
check king of 70 gave one
yeah I morning giving a full look with
this or yes I am I able to know I can
also you can just take the rope here
this is easiest not give the check a
check would win but this is much better
okay wow wow that's that's that's crazy
I'm really just lost after Queen age
five I have to have to take him and I
need to take here first I let Shaq
played that by far too quickly jam that
maybe this is not a good idea the
capture on f4 that's very interesting
the normal move here is to play
something like be six but I just wanted
to try this out the thing is that black
is not worried about this structure
white could have done that one move
earlier and black is ok here you can go
g5 and this is perfectly fine but I felt
that this is interesting but it really
seems to be bad I e5 is exceptionally
strong
so I took this you have to take on
everyone absolutely after this I'm lost
him and he I'm just totally lost now it
doesn't matter anymore it's totally lost
okay then i had to her absolutely after
Boucherie five i just had to think for a
moment and really ask myself actively
here like paws yourself that question
what exactly is my move after Queen age
five and you're pretty quickly see that
it's not an obvious move at all you have
no obvious choice if you go here for
example check check and the issue is you
have nowhere to go yeah there's f7 SSS
is some yeah he just don't check check
let's just check here for made 28 is one
move quicker even if 5 is strong now
it's not the end of the world I just
have to take here and at least I'm
avoiding the immediate disaster this is
also a lot worse compared to that
because now I have Queen have checks
here which helps so I cashew the shaking
king queen takes and politics yeah white
has definite compensation my development
is not great this is them probably the
true to core of the matter I'm just not
developed well enough to open up on f4 i
just i should play here early and then
it's again for wide the question if he
wants to take on if I or not v6 is
helpful in any case as I need to save
myself against that pressure
on the B file so that my bishop can
actually move and in a key in this soups
that's by the way that to move but if
why it takes the possible this should be
three then it's not attacking the pawn
yeah this is what I have to do that's
really important to remember the opening
of the position here with taking on
therefore it's not a good idea okay
thanks for watching